HARRIS: Good evening.
I'm Ellen Harris, Associate
Provost for the Arts,
and it's my very
special pleasure
to welcome you tonight to this
showcase concert of MIT student
music-making.
I want to take an opportunity
to point out to you,
to emphasize that, however
wonderful this concert is,
that it is only a fraction
of the music-making that goes
on at MIT, and I urge you--
after the concert,
not during the music
-to read the center portion
of your program, which
will give you some
more information
about the kind of music-making
that goes on here.
And I'd like to say, beyond
that, that, of course,
music-making is only a fraction
of the arts on this campus.
We also have many programs
in the visual arts,
in theater, in dance, and in
writing, to name but a few.
And we'll try to schedule
showcase concerts for all
of those things down the line.
We'll let you know.
Of course, it
wouldn't be a concert
if there weren't
an announcement.
So let me make the announcement
for the evening, which
is that we are very sorry that
John Oliver, the conductor
of the chamber
choir, will not be
able to conduct
tonight because he has
a very painful fractured foot.
We are happy, however,
to have William C.
Cutter, the Assistant Conductor,
who will be conducting,
not only tonight, but tomorrow
at the Inauguration, also.
And we are very
lucky, and we are
very happy to have
Mr. Cutter with us.
I would also like
to invite all of you
to come to the Student Center
following the concert--
to the third floor, where you
can meet the student performers
and composers whose work is
being highlighted tonight.
They and I look forward
to greeting you there.
Thank you very much.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSICIANS TUNING]
[ORCHESTRA PLAYING]
[APPLAUSE]
[RUSTLING AND MURMURS]
[MUSICIANS TUNING]
[APPLAUSE]
[ORCHESTRA PLAYING]
[RUSTLING AND MURMURS]
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC - CHARLES POKORNY,
LYRICS - WILLIAM S. BURROUGHS,
"QUICK"]
VOCALIST (SINGING): White
flash, mangled insect screams.
I woke up with the taste
of metal in my mouth,
back from the dead.
Trailing the colorless
death smells.
Afterbirth of a
withered grey monkey.
Phantom twinges of amputation.
"Taxi boys waiting
for a pickup,"
Eduardo said, and died
of an overdose in Madrid.
Powder trains burn back
through pink convolutions
of tumescent flesh.
Set off flash bulbs of orgasm.
Pin-point photos
of arrested motion.
Smooth brown side twisted
to light a cigarette.
He stood there in a 1920s
straw hat somebody gave him.
Soft, mendicant words
falling like dead birds
in the dark street.
No.
No more.
No más.
A heaving sea of air hammers
in the purple brown dusk
tainted with rotten
metal smell of sewer gas.
Young worker faces
vibrating out of focus
in yellow halos of
carbide lanterns.
Broken pipes exposed.
"They are rebuilding the
" Lee nodded absently.
"Yes, always."
Either way is a bad
move to The East Wing.
If I knew, I'd be
glad to tell you.
"No good.
No bueno hustling myself.
No glot.
C'lom Fliday."
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC - RIGOPOULOS,
LYRICS - THOMAS HARDY,
"BEFORE LIFE AND AFTER"]
VOCALIST (SINGING): A time
there was, as one may guess.
And as, indeed, earth's
testimonies tell.
Before the birth
of consciousness,
when all went well.
None suffered sickness,
love, or loss.
None knew regret, starved
hope, or a heart-burnings.
None cared whatever crash or
cross brought wrack to things.
If something ceased,
no tongue bewailed.
If something winced and
waned, no heart was wrung.
If brightness dimmed, and dark
prevailed, no sense was stung.
But the disease of feeling
germed and primal rightness
took the tinct of wrong.
Ere nescience shall
be reaffirmed.
How long, how long?
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC - CYNTHIA HARRIS,
LYRICS - WILLIAM BLAKE,
"HOW SWEET I ROAM'D
FROM FIELD TO FIELD"]
VOCALIST (SINGING): How sweet
I roamed from field to field,
and tasted all the
summer's pride.
Till I, the prince of love
beheld who in the sunny beams
did glide.
He shew'd me lilies for my hair,
and blushing roses for my brow.
He led me through
his gardens fair,
where all his golden
pleasures grow.
With sweet May dews
my wings were wet,
and Phoebus fir'd my vocal rage.
He caught me in his silken net,
and shot me in his golden cage.
He loves to sit and hear
me sing, then, laughing,
sports and plays with me.
Then stretches out my
golden wing and mocks
my loss of liberty.
How sweet I roamed
from field to field,
and tasted all the
summer's pride.
Till I, the prince of love
beheld who in the sunny beams
did glide.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC - YUMI OSHIMA, LYRICS -
WILLIAM BLAKE, "SPRING"]
VOCALIST (SINGING): Sound
the flute now it's mute.
Birds delight, nightingale.
Lark in sky day and night.
Birds delight.
Day and night.
Nightingale in the dale.
Lark in sky.
Merrily, merrily,
merrily to welcome in--
in the year.
Little boy full of joy.
Little girl, little
girl, sweet and small.
Little boy, little girl.
Sweet and small.
Cock does crow.
So do you.
Merry voice, infant noise.
Merry, merry, merrily, merrily.
Merrily, merrily to
welcome in the year.
Little lamb, little lamb.
Little lamb, here I am.
Come and lick my white neck.
Let me pull your soft wool.
Let me kiss your soft face.
Little lamb, here I am.
Come and lick my white neck.
Let me pull your soft wool.
Let me kiss you soft face.
Merrily, merrily to
welcome in the year.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC - DUKE ELLINGTON, ARR.
RICKS, "PARADISE COMPLETE"]
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC - HOAGY CARMICHAEL, ARR.
WARREN, ADAPTED BY
VALDEZ, "A QUIET PLACE"]
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC - JAMSHIED SHARIFI, "THE
CHANGE"]
[APPLAUSE]